- [Envy] Check, check, check.
Is the mic on?
- [Ja Rule] Aye!
- Can we make it
louder a little bit or...?
We're good, okay.
- Yo!
Check, check.
- Is yours on?
- [Ja Rule] Check, check.
I don't really need a mic!
(audience laughter)
I got, like, a
built in mic and shit.
(laughs)
Yo, pass me that--
- No, it's on.
- Yo!
- There you go.
- Ha hah, there we go.
Shit, ya'll can turn me
down little bit. (chuckles)
- So, GaryVee.
Can you turn the
mic on a little bit,
or do I have to do what Ja did,
just put the mic down?
(laughs)
Check, check, check, check,
check, check, check, check,
check, check, check.
Alright, so GaryVee is here.
(audience cheering)
- Thanks, mom.
- [Envy] A lot inspiration
out there about investing
and things of that nature,
so what should people
be looking at right now
as far as investments
and making some real money?
What should we be looking at?
- Well, I think
we need to actually,
and this is not
going to be as hype
and everybody's not going to
be pumped with this answer,
but I'm pushing practicality.
You know, we got eight
years of a good economy,
like this world of
ours, and this is amb...
I mean, if you're here,
you're ambitious,
you know what's
going on in the new world,
you're hyped,
you've got a lot of energy,
entrepreneurial,
and you're a risk taker.
The problem is
when I look at this crowd,
there's so many young people
who've never lived
through the punch in the mouth.
- [Ja Rule] Yeah, yeah.
- You know? (chuckles)
- [Ja Rule] I've lived through
the punch in the mouth.
(laughs)
Trust me. (laughs)
- So, after eight
great years in our economy,
I want people to pay attention
to actually making money.
You know, users, and
engagement, and followers,
you know, lifetime value,
CAC, all this stuff that
people talk about
in the startup world
is all nice and dandy,
but if your business
is not making money each month
and it's losing money,
you're not going
to be raising money
when there's none out there.
And so, I'm
pushing practicality.
It's boring,
but it's tried and true.
- [Envy] Now,
let me ask you, Ja.
Now, Ja's a
multimillion selling artist.
- [Ja Rule] Yeah.
- [Envy] You had your ups and
downs, you were locked up,
you went to jail.
- [Ja Rule] Yep.
- [Envy] But you
never lost a step.
You've...
- [Man] 'Cause he's from Queens!
(laughs)
(audience cheering)
- You know that!
- You've been great
with your investments,
you've been great...
You know, we've
never seen you lose a car,
we never seen any repos,
so explain to the
people what you did
to make sure that your
fortune was still intact.
- I mean, you know...
First thing that
happened to me that
was a red flag that went off
and it probably
was the best thing
that happened
to me was the beef,
because I realized
that
my livelihood
was
in a business
that is subjective.
You guys don't
have to like Ja Rule.
You don't have to like Drake.
You don't have to like Envy.
But tech is different.
You know,
everybody uses Instagram.
Everybody uses Snapchat.
Everybody, you know,
uses these things because
they're a necessity.
So, that was a blessing
in disguise for me because
I realized that I need to,
you know, get
something with little bit more
substance to carry me
through my forties and beyond.
And, so, I started looking
into, getting into, you know
tech, tech world and
investing in
different companies.
And, so far I've invested in
about four companies and
one just exited, so
we just got a nice...
(audience cheering)
- That's always good.
- And I founded
another one, which is Fyre,
which is doing really well.
We're profitable and--
- [Envy] Now tell the people
what Fyre is if they don't know.
- Fyre is basically a
booking app for all talent.
So, we basically
cut out the middle man.
It's a shit show, you know,
when you trying to book talent.
A lot of you guys
out here, you know,
that are young
entrepreneurs, you know,
with nice healthy bank accounts
probably can
afford some of the talent,
but don't know
how to get to them and
would love to have a Ja Rule or
somebody at
these type of events.
So, at your corporate,
you know, Christmas party,
or bar mitzvah, you could say--
(laughs)
Whatever!
Me and my partner, we
created this platform for
people such as yourselves,
the private sector,
and also, you
know, professional
buyers as well,
to really cut
through all the red tape
and get to the artists
that they want to get to,
you know, real
seamless and transparent.
- [Envy] So, with the app,
what makes the app so dope is
let's say you wanna book...
Let's say you
wanna book GaryVee.
- Good idea!
- [Envy] Good idea!
(audience laughter)
- [Ja Rule] Great idea!
- [Envy] So, instead of going
through a booking agent
and going through management,
you put your offer
in and it goes directly
to GaryVee's app.
- Yeah.
- GaryVee can decide
if he wants to accept that
or decline, or say, "I need
more money", or, "less money",
or whatever it may
be and it's direct.
You don't have to
worry about the agents.
worry about bookings fees.
It's direct to the
consumer, which is dope.
- [Ja Rule] Which
is really dope.
- Now GaryVee, you
get a lot of shit sometimes
for telling people about
themselves and telling people
to get off their ass.
(audience laughter)
All the time, so tell people
about why you are so hard
on people about getting off
their ass and getting into
investing, doing
some of the things you do.
- Truth is, I'm only saying
that to people that complain.
Like the problem is, most
people are complaining, right?
Like my advice is very basic,
I just don't understand why
you would complain
versus doing something about it.
Everybody's got something.
Everybody's got
some issue, minorities,
the family you grew up with,
the neighborhood you came from,
got screwed by this person,
all the kids that were told
to go to college and amassed
a tremendous amount of debt
to get a good job,
fucked, all of them.
You know, so I think that,--
- Very true (laughing)
- For me,
there's a lot of people
that have personal brands
that put out content
that are tricking people
and they don't want them to
succeed and they wanna just
get money from them
to make money themselves,
make a couple
thousand bucks on their course.
I want the people that watch
me to eventually never watch me
again, my big thesis is to
have less followers not more
because I want to give
the tools and the blueprint
for them to go do instead of
reading another fucking book
or going to another
fucking conference.
Like eventually all that shit
is just disguised excuses
'cause you don't wanna
put in the actual work
that it takes to win.
(audience cheering)
- [Ja Rule] Right, I agree.
- Truth, 100%.
- [Envy] You know, one thing
about GaryVee, you know when
I first met GaryVee I really
wasn't fond of him,
I really didn't like him.
(audience laughter)
And I'm gonna tell you
why, because you hear this
all the time from
inspiration speakers--
- Yeah
- [Envy] and they tell you what
you should do and it
seems like it's a rip-off.
You should be working harder!
You should do this!
And I tested GaryVee
liive on air and I said well,
since you know so much Mr. Vee,--
(audience laughter)
- He did.
- Tell the people who
listen right now what they
need to do, and he broke
it down, what people can do
to make money 'cus
that's a lot of people's thing,
they say well I have money but
I don't know what to invest,
I don't know how to
read the stock market,
I don't know what I can invest
in that will make me money.
I don't want to lose my
saving and you came up with
some great ideas which made
me love GaryVee, like he's
really about helping people.
- My big thing that I got lucky
with is I know how to make
money outside, like the
money I've made in my life
has been about
building business.
I built a liquor store, like
I built an agency that goes
after Fortune 50 companies.
I'm not trying to get their
money like a lot of people
that look that part, so
for me it's the other way,
I'm trying to disproportionally
help because that's legacy.
I'm gonna get my
currency elsewhere.
This is about legacy, this
is about people emailing you
and saying fuck,
you helped my life.
That shit, listen, when I get
an email from my team of like
we won an RFP,
I don't give a fuck.
You get an email from somebody
who's like I was on welfare
and now I'm not because I
watched fucking Breakfast Club.
I'm like fuck,
that's some crazy shit.
(audience laughter)
That feels better.
I've always been able to
make money, that's my talent.
You can make art, people have
skills, I'm good at that.
This now with the
communication paths we have,
it's why I love doing your
show, a lot of fucking people
listen to your show.
- [Ja Rule] Yeah.
- I can go on there and
use that distribution to help
somebody and then
that builds legacy,
that's how you build brand.
I'm in for marathon
money not sprint money.
(audience cheering)
- [Envy] There you go.
- [Ja Rule] absolutely.
Wealth.
- [Envy] Now what
about you, Ja,
as far as investing, what
do you look for in a company
when you're looking
to invest and put money
towards something?
- [Ja Rule] It depends.
You know I'm a passionate guy.
I go with things
that I'm passionate about
that I can actually
go out there and promote
with my heart.
If I can't do that then
I'm not gonna fuck with it
because it's not real to me, so,
I look for things that
I'm interested in that I think
are great companies
that have a future, not just
a quick exit strategy,
but actually some companies
have a real real plan of how
they want to change the world
and move things forward and
move our culture forward so
I love those type of companies.
- [Envy] Now what
about you GaryVee?
You know another reason
I didn't really like you
is 'cause you a Jets
fan and I'm a Giants fan.
(audience cheering)
- Keenan!
- You said one
of your main goals
is to actually buy the Jets.
I don't know why you'd wanna
do that, maybe the Giants.
- Gary I want in on that
- You got it Ja, I wanna
do it ''cause we need
a fucking Super Bowl.
(laughing)
- [Envy] So now when you're
lookin' to acquire in somethin'
and invest, what do you look at?
- In this world,
in the South-by world,
I look for the
jockey over the horse,
so I'm looking at
does she have the fire
to change her business
nine months in when
the market changed on her?
- [Ja Rule] Mhmmm.
So in startup land, it's hard.
- [Ja Rule] Yeah.
Like, when you're
building something from zero,
like in public, like let
me tell you guys like all
to make money.
No joke, if
you're sitting on money,
every person here
should invest in Facebook,
and then when the
world melts in nine months
and the stocks in
half and you hate me,
don't sell it, just hold on,
because I promise
you in nine years,
that investment's gonna return
you a fuck load of money.
That's the slow, double
or triple your money bet,
but that's kind of better
than the fucking zero interest
you get in the bank.
The way to make
crazy money is to only bet
on the jockey,
because they've got to pivot,
they've got to adjust.
You know,
the operator, the pilot,
she and he is the one
that's gonna dominate and win
because the reality is,
these startups are
so young and early.
Facebook looks nothing
like what Facebook looked like
nine years ago.
He made a bunch of adjustments.
Like this shit changes,
and you've got
to be used to that.
Spotify had to adjust.
Birchbox has to adjust.
Like everybody's navigating
and just raising capital
or looking the part,
so I'm looking for
somebody who can get
punched in the mouth,
spit the blood out
and move forward.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- [Woman] I'm right here.
- [Envy] She thinks
she's it right there.
- You got it.
- [Ja Rule] I like that.
- I like that.
- [Envy] Is there anything else
that you wanna tell the people
since we have 'em here and
they're sitting here listening?
- Ja?
- No, I just wanna, you know,
get on that what you just said.
The adjust.
You know, my company Fyre is,
we're eight months in
and we've probably
adjusted twice already,
you know?
(laughs)
Because, when you
start a company you realize
these things sometimes have
legs of their own and they
take on different
turns that you didn't expect,
and you gotta go ahead and
attack those situations, so
I'm 100 percent in agreement
with adjustment, man.
- Can we do maybe like
two or three questions?
- [Envy] Yeah, absolutely.
Anybody got questions?
- [Lisa] Yeah.
- Go ahead.
- [Envy] You gotta yell loud.
- [Lisa] Hi!
- Hi.
- [Lisa] So what
would be your advice for
someone who's trying
to scale their company?
I have an alcohol infused
cupcake company in Las Vegas.
- An alcohol
infused cupcake company.
- [Envy] Cool.
(audience laughter)
- [Lisa] Called Sin City Cupcakes.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I like that too.
(audience laughter)
- Go ahead.
- [Lisa] Year five.
- Year five
- [Lisa] Year five, and my goal,
I have a partner, she and
I met in the modeling industry
like ten years ago.
- Okay.
- [Lisa] My goal's
to build and sell.
- Okay.
- [Lisa] So we've had some
players talk to us, but we
made a couple million.
Everything's good but I wanna
take it to like ten million.
- Okay.
- [Lisa] We're based in Vegas,
which is a great place, if
you're coming to overspend,
overindulge, buy things you're
not gonna buy at home, right?
You will spend $52 for
a dozen alcohol cupcakes.
- Yep.
- [Lisa] But to take that to
a ten million dollar company,
I feel like we have to go
outside of Las Vegas,--
- Okay.
- [Lisa] and I don't know if
we've pigeon holed ourselves,
as Sin City Cupcakes.
- So, a brand can
change all the time, right?
Like, just 'cause
you're called Sin City,
doesn't mean it
won't work somewhere else.
You just have to execute.
The bigger question is,
how does your model change when
people are not
buying $52 cupcakes
because they're not drunk as
fuck and it's that one weekend
they have to escape.
- [Lisa] Right.
- Right? So, when
they're in Dallas...
Now, what I would do is,
I would level it up
mentally into escapism.
What Vegas
really is is escapism.
It's a break
from your reality.
- [Lisa] Right.
- So if you're gonna
go to New York or L.A.,
or Dallas or Miami,
there's pockets, even though
the whole city isn't that,
there's pockets of escapism,
and so you should
reverse engineer the psychology
of the people that
actually buy your product
and then level that up,
and that's how
I would think about
second and third locations.
What replicates the
mentality of the decision maker
in those places.
Mhmmm.
- [Envy] Now one thing GaryVee
told me on the Breakfast Club
that stuck with me,
is of course with the
Breakfast Club you have
a lot of following
on social media
and we sell a lot
of different things,
like there's merchandise,
we own a juice bar,
a carwash, different things,
but he said you have to
use your social media right.
In the bio of my social media,
I was sending it to
all different places,
but what he said on
the Breakfast Club was,
in your bio,
when people click it,
make it to where there
can go and purchase something,
not just randomly
clicking to your podcast,
not randomly clicking,
and we've seen sales
of the juice bar shoot up,
by just changing
that little thing.
And I wanted to say
thank you for that.
- I think the one
thing I can tell all of you
and again, looking at the demo,
you have to be the architect
and the plumber, right?
And the mason, and
the garbageperson.
Like the thing that
I have a lot of pride in,
is I can come on
and talk all high level
and then when somebody calls
me to the mat like you did,
the reason I love you is,
I do a lot of shit,
and I just pontificate,
and nobody calls me
to the mat,--
- [Envy] Yeah, yeah.
- we run out of time and I leave.
You called me to the
mat, I'm like, "Okay."
But what I'm excited
about is that's my best moment,
because if you
wanna go into details,
I'll get so
finite into that detail,
so to me, the one
thing I would pride myself in
as you grow in your business...
How many people here
have a business that has more
than five employees?
Great, ten?
Twenty?
Great, so like I said,
look around, this is great.
There's enough
to talk about this.
As you grow, the thing
that I have the most pride in,
is VaynerMedia
now has 800 employees.
Not one of them
that works for me
does as much actual
social media as I do.
I'm still, by far,
and that's probably
the biggest reason,
my side hustle is GaryVee,
is because it keeps me
grounded in actually the doing
of the shit that I'm doing,
and what happens to a
lot of people as they grow,
they get away from the work
and they become a manager
and then they
don't know what the fuck
they're talking about.
(audience laughter)
- [Ja Rule] I'm terrible
at social media,
(laughing)
- But real quick Ja,
if that's not
your actual business--
- [Ja Rule] That's
not my business.
- Then that's
a different thing.
If that's part of your business,
but if it's your
actual fuckin' business,
the amount of people
that roll up on me like,
"Gary I got a social
media agency this Sunday."
I ask them four social
media tactical questions,
and they have no fuckin' idea.
I'm like you ain't shit.
You're full of shit, dick.
(audience laughter)
Sorry, I'm getting fired.
(laughing)
- This is how people
fuckin' get fired up,
and they go home
and do great shit.
- That's what I think!
- Any other questions
for GaryVee or Ja?
- [Woman] Yeah,
I have a question.
- Go ahead, over here.
Oh! There you are.
- [Woman] So, I know,
Ireland to here.
- I know, I love it.
- [Woman] We're only as
strong as our team right?
And I really
appreciate my interns,
so what can I do to create
the most amazing
internship experience
so they optimize
growing as a professional?
- Ja, your
perspective on internship.
- Man, you know,
I would like to see,
interns are easy to me,
because your interns should
want to grow with the company
and wanna run through walls
and do everything
possible to help you win
and to take their
career to the next level.
So for me, interns are easy.
It's more, I look at the
employees at my workplace
where I feel as though
I take on a kind of a new way
of nurturing my
employees, you know,
kinda giving them that
five o'clock break to go to
fuckin' yoga or whatever
the fuck they want to do,
the gym or whatever.
Give them a longer lunch.
You know let them go out
you don't gotta eat
lunch in the office.
Go have a good
time, come on back.
Because it keeps them focused,
it keeps them wanting
to work for the company,
it keeps them
wanting to be great.
And I think that
those things help, you know,
nurture and grow your business.
- I have a pretty similar answer
with one little twist.
To me, whether it's
interns or employees,
you have to reverse
engineer them one by one.
So Ja's talking about a
lot of people who do wanna
take a break,
can't keep concentration
and hustle for 14 hours a day.
Meanwhile, somebody
else as an intern wants
to work 19 hours a day everyday,
'cause they want
you to pay more money.
I'm pumped that I
know that Ben Benrubi
who's sitting
right there came to me.
You have to be open to
him and making him feel safe
that when he came into
my office six months ago
and said, "Yo bro, I
don't want to be known
"just as a Snapchat guy."
I'm like cool Ben I get that.
Or Emily and the
four different functions
she's done at VeynerCayner
Or Steph Bagley
who worked at Vayner,
but I always knew
had other ambitions,
and I helped her
get that next job right?
Or Kim Garcia,
who's so fucking
ambitious and monster,
I'm always sweating when
I have a meeting with her
because I know I have to step up
and give her more challenges.
And our last conversation was,
do I have something
for you which I created,
or was thing going to
be the end of our thing?
Those are four or
five different people,
who have four or
five different things,
and I'm trying to
scale that with 800 people.
I wanna know, do
you want to make...
I love when people are like,
"Millennials like
work-life balance."
Millennials want
fuckin' cash too.
(audience laughter)
- Absolutely.
- And so if you're a
millennial that wants cash,
then you gotta
like, when people,
I love when people are like,
"Gary, I wanna be
the CEO of this company."
When I meet with
them, I'm like, Mazel Tov.
I'm like, you need
to work 20 hours a day
every day for the next 13 years.
And then they're like, alright
let me think about that.
(audience laughter)
So I don't want to, for
an intern, it's super simple.
You go right up to her and say,
"Katherine, what the
fuck do you want out of this?"
She may say,
"I want a job here."
You'll tell her
how to work on things.
She may say, "I know
that you know GaryVee
"and I wanna work
at VaynerMedia."
Then you should email me.
You can't make
the call for them.
You need to
figure out what it is,
and then put them in
that position to succeed
one by one by one.
-[Ja Rule] Yep.
(audience applause)
- [Envy] Alright.
- [Ja Rule] absolutely.
- [Envy] Any other questions?
Go ahead.
- [Man] So you know,
as entrepreneurs,
as we grow and everything,
I'm wondering Gary,
how do you stay in
touch with your employees?
Okay, because everybody
like us goes through highs,
goes through lows, it's
never as good as it seems,
it's never as bad as it seems.
How do you, you know,
authenticate to them
the challenges
they're going through
and, you know,
have that communication.
- I don't.
I do not have any
interest in my employees
worrying about my headaches.
I'm the CEO.
I mean that, I don't need...
- [Man] They're headaches.
- Their headaches
are what I just told you
which is my door is open.
Most of them
don't take me up on it,
so then I watch
them and I listen.
I've got 100 people
internally that give me
optics to the other 700.
I follow all 800
of them on social
and try to pay attention.
I created an HR
division that is much more
on the offense and
not about the paperwork,
hiring and firing, and
I just try the best I can.
I mean you just
do the best you can.
It's no different than
parenting, running a business,
putting out, you just do like,
everybody's
beating themselves up.
If you just do the
best you can, that's...
It's the intent my man.
The intent is what matters.
For the most part,
eventually they know
that's actually
what I give a fuck about,
and then that's
what wins it over.
It's not the tactics,
it's the religion.
- [Ja Rule] For me, I just
wanna answer that too
because I have a
different thing going on,
because I'm, you know, Ja Rule.
(audience laughter)
No, but it's for real.
But I say that to say
a lot of my employees
were kids that listened
and grew up to my music.
- Yeah.
- And so they're somewhat fans.
So I'm not always in the office
you know because I travel and
I gotta move around still.
But I make it my
business to go into the office
and see what
they're doing, say hi,
because I know at some
point they probably think
I don't give a fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
They're like Ja's
busy and Ja's doing Ja,
but I make it my
business to come in there
and let em' know I'm
interested in what you're doing,
I got my eye on
what you're doing,
and I wanna be a
part of, you know,
what you guys are
doing every day all day.
So if you have,
and a second thing,
if you have any questions,
come in my office,
my door's open.
And I'll come and stop
down in their stations too
just to check one em'
and make em' feel wanted
and part of the company.
- The other thing,
do you have a company?
- [Man] Yep!
- And how many
employees do you have?
- [Man] About 40.
- Great.
The biggest key, this is subtle,
you can't let your five
to six more senior people
think they have any
more equity with you
than your bottom five or six.
- [Ja Rule] True.
- It's such a big one.
- [Ja Rule] Yeah.
- One of the best
things going for Vayner,
most people don't
know it, a good amount do,
and the one's that do love it.
I won't take an SVP's
word over a community manager.
It's just two human beings.
And a lot of times, the
truth is the bigger you get,
they more politics you
play to keep the people
underneath you, cause
you're just trying to hold on
to your $200,000 job.
So the biggest thing
that I would tell you at 40,
is make sure those five
are on even playing field
with the bottom five, and
everybody fuckin' knows it.
- [Ja Rule] Yep.
- [Envy] Other questions?
- [Man 2] What are your thoughts
on Puerto Rico becoming
the next Silicon Valley
from the tax exemption?
- Puerto Rico because
of the tax exemption?
- [Man 2] Yeah, the tax exemption.
- You think it's gonna
be the next Silicon Valley?
- [Man 2] There's a lot
of companies moving there.
- I'm aware.
- [Man 2] Like 4%.
- You think it's gonna
be the next Silicon Valley?
- [Man 2] A lot of companies--
- That's not what I asked you.
(audience laughter)
You think 4% tax
is gonna bring all
the best tech talent in
the world to Puerto Rico?
- [Man 2] Not only that but--
- But that's what makes
Silicon Valley Silicon Valley.
Silicon Valley's advantage
is that when you graduate,
whether you're in Boston
or Puerto Rico or Sweden,
you want to move
to Silicon Valley.
They have the brand game won.
And they have the
engineers and the tech talent.
There's a lot of
business talent here.
As I look around, not a lot
of hardcore backend developers
chilling with us tonight, right?
(audience laughter)
To build the
biggest companies...
Respect my man. Respect.
My man, raise your hand again.
Give it up for that man!
Let's go baby, yeah!
So the thing, my man, that a
lot of people misunderstand,
is the engineering
talent to build
the biggest
companies in the world.
That's where they all go.
And until that changes,
that's the hard thing
for New York or L.A.
or other places to crack.
The biggest
thing Puerto Rico needs
is what's happening in L.A.
When you start creating
millionaires and billionaires
off a big exit like Snapchat,
and then that creates
the whole ecosystem.
Puerto Rico, much like
Boston, New York, Austin,
needs that monstrous
10, 20, 40, $80 billion exit
and it then spits out
all those billionaires
that stay in Puerto Rico
and build up the ecosystem.
That's the key to
unlock the next Silicon Valley.
- Alright.
- [Envy] Another question?
Right here?
- [Scott] Gary, over the
years I've interviewed you
five or six times
for different things.
- Yes, yes.
- [Scott] You've
obviously now started looking
at strategic ways to
develop not just an agency
but a sports division.
- Yes.
- [Scott] All these
different companies.
When you look at
the VC world, right now?
- The VC world.
- [Man 3] Do you see a
mass consolidation happening
with that industry as
people see your model,
which is not necessarily
investment by dollars per-se
but investment by services,
where is the
relevancy of VCs long term?
- I think VC is gonna go through
a really difficult time soon.
I really do.
It's a bubble and a half--
- Yes sir.
- Over-evaluations, so VC is
gonna do what it's always done
in three or four
cycles, you know.
VC, as you know, and we have
been jammin' for a long time.
2005-6, this whole new
Web 2.0 thing comes
and then everybody's a VC.
Right everybody's an
investor, and an angel investor,
and everybody's got a startup.
The second we have a
macroeconomic slow down,
which we will, we haven't
had one since 2008.
I think VC is gonna
consolidate dramatically.
LPs are gonna
pour less money in.
And we'll have a complete reset.
All the B and C and D players
in here will get exposed
and go work at fucking TD bank.
(audience laughter)
And then the real
entrepreneurs will take more.
Like, the amount
of wealth creation--
- [Scott] Like what
happened in '08.
- Exactly, the
amount of wealth creation
that I'm gonna
have in the next chapter
is going to be extraordinary
because I'm going to buy up
a lot of people's in
this room's businesses
for a penny on the dollar.
- [Scott] So my question then
is, do you think more companies
are going to start
seeing that and being more like
what you're doing
through your Vayner enterprise?
- What you're saying
is very smart, my friend.
Yes I think smart
money will always win.
If you take my
million dollar check,
you have a marketing
machine behind you.
You have me.
And the reason we're
going to sports agency world is,
Roc Nation's great but,
you know, Jay-Z is busy.
Right, like
he's not helping you.
He's leveraging his name.
And I'm nowhere close to that,
but I will use my assets.
The guys I have are about
to make so much more money
off the field than the people
that get drafted
three rounds ahead of them.
I have a funny feeling that's
going to work in my favor
in the next draft class.
(audience member whistles)
- You wanna be?
- [Woman 2] Choose me.
(audience laughter)
- You're chosen. Done.
- [Woman 2] I got you.
- I'm in.
(audience laughter)
- Bet.
- [Woman 2] All the way.
- Done.
(audience clapping)
- Alright, and this
is the last question.
Last question anybody?
- [Man 4] Right here, I got one.
- Go ahead.
- [Man 4] I'm down
here, I'm right here.
- Alright.
- [Man 4] So, Gary and Ja I want
both your perspectives on this.
You said a lot about
betting on the jockey,
not on the horse.
- Yeah.
- [Man 4] So what
happens when the jockeys
are really
really good salespeople,
but they haven't figured out
how to scale the business yet.
Do you still bet on them?
Or do you want
them to figure out both
before they get to you.
- Ja?
- As a VC?
- [Man 4] Angel investor,
you know somebody
who's going to help monetarily
as well as other resources.
- You know, it's so
much due diligence that goes
into that type
of stuff, you know.
I don't like to
invest in something
that I don't think is a home run
or I don't think they have
their shit all the way together.
You know what I mean?
And I won't do it just because
it's a passion thing for me.
I gotta believe in it.
I gotta want to carry
this thing on my back too.
So certain situations like
that I may slide away from.
- The way I think I heard
you ask the question
is you feel like you're
really great or your team
are really great
salespeople but you haven't had
the ability before
to scale a business
so you don't know
how to do that yet?
- [Man 4] Not yet.
- Yeah.
- So I'm gonna say something
that I think you'll like.
Which is great.
I'm a big fan of
betting on salespeople.
Sales DNA is a very good idea.
Making money has a funny way
of fixing a lot of problems.
- [Man 4] Ah, shit!
(audience laughter)
- So if you ask me,
I love sales driven CEOs,
but I have to see what
your business is about, right?
If you're a great salesperson,
but your product is jack shit
it's not going to matter.
So there's a lot of
factors that go into it.
But if I had my way, the
person is the slight thing
that I would bet on.
But I have to
believe in their thesis.
If you're like,
hey, we're selling
this detox fucking
mushroom soup--
- [Man 4] Or selling snake oil--
- I'm like fuck that.
- [Man 4] You have to be pretty
good at selling snake oil.
- Exactly, yeah exactly.
- [Man 4] Got it.
- Cool.
- [Man 4] Appreciate it.
- Thank you guys.
- Now we're closing you
got something in closing?
- [Envy] Closing? Ja?
- It's 2017 let's go out
and get some fucking money.
(audience laughter)
- [Envy] GaryVee? GaryVee?
- God, fuck that was perfect.
You know, I would say, let's
go make some actual money
because shit's
about to hit the fan
and making money is
a very good strategy.
- [Envy] Alright.
- It's a funny thing to say
but this, like, South-by,
is loaded with people
that are building apps
and building thesises but
don't know how to make money.
- [Envy] Give it up
for GaryVee, Ja Rule.
(audience cheering)
- [Gary] Great job,
you did a great job.
(bright music)